Vielleicht geht dieser sommer in die geschichtsbücher ein amerika europa afrika asien
der klimawandel ist zum greifen in schweden also in schweden nur noch mal zur erinnerung das ist das land im hohen norden
geraten waldbrände außer kontrolle in deutschland hatten wir den heißesten april und den heißesten seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen und so ist es weltweit von überall werden rekorde gemeldet und aus dem iran
die ersten aufstände es wird schlimm es ist der wahnsinn klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
30 grad und mehr und das seit wochen
viele fragen sich schon ob das vielleicht der neue jahrhundert sondern wird seit mehreren wochen herrscht dürre in vielen regionen deutschlands
und vor allem für den osten und norden bedeutet dass eine schleichende wetter katastrophe ist die dürre
2018 vergleichbar mit dem jahrhundertsommer 2003 bei dem mehrere
10.000 menschen starben wie ungewöhnlich ist diese trockenheit für deutschland und kommen in der zukunft weitere wetterkatastrophen auf uns zu
die aktuelle wetter katastrophe spielt sich vor allem von emden bis zum erzgebirge
ab der westen und süden die haben dagegen in der vergangenen zeit mit krassen regenfällen ja fast sturzfluten zu kämpfen gehabt vor allem osten
deutschlands hat der wassermangel und die daraus entstehende
katastrophale folgen einige regionen sind so trocken wie seit dem beginn der
wetteraufzeichnung noch nie in sachsen anhalt und thüringen ist der boden bis zu zwei meter tief
ausgetrocknet auch im norden gibt es eine schwere schwere dürre bis tief in den boden hinein in
niedersachsen kamen die wasserwerke nicht mehr hinterher um den wasserbedarf aus eigener kraft zu stemmen doch bei allen
grund zur sorge steht auch fest die versorgung mit trinkwasser in deutschland ist wirklich nur in
ausnahmefällen gefährdet in anderen regionen der welt ist das anders im iran sind 97 prozent des landes von anhaltender trockenheit
betroffen in mehreren städten dort gibt es einfach kein trinkwasser mehr die bevölkerung
protestierte dagegen es sollen bei
auseinandersetzungen mit der polizei
demonstranten erschossen worden seien angeblich ist ein rohrbruch schuld doch der iran leidet unter einem fehler im system
hervorgerufen durch den klimawandel
die temperaturen stiegen hier bereits doppelt so stark als im durchschnitt auf der erde um bis zu zwei grad der
wasserverbrauch ist dabei immens die vereinten nationen empfehlen
20 prozent der wassermenge zu verbrauchen die durch regen wieder aufgefüllt wird im iran sind es
110 prozent dem land geht einfach das wasser aus es wird wohl nicht mehr vermeidbar sein dass zwölf von
31 provinzen in naher zukunft unbewohnbar werden die folgen durch hunger revolten und damit die
instabilität der ganzen region
nach europa doch selbst hier in europa wird es unangenehm gerade ist der pegel der elbe in dresden auf
55 zentimeter gefallen und auch andere flüsse in betroffenen gebieten führen deutlich weniger wasser als sonst die folgen bei uns der
warenverkehr über die flüsse ist gar nicht mehr oder nur eingeschränkt möglich beispielsweise zwischen dresden und magdeburg
das alles wird jetzt auf die straßen beziehungsweise schiene verlagert was deutlich mehr kostet und oft auch mehr zeit in anspruch nimmt
eine andere folge der hitze hier
pflanzen sterben ab und brände haben bereits mehrere hundert hektar wald verwüstet was aber nichts gegen die waldbrand katastrophe
in schweden ist insgesamt gibt es dort 50
waldbrände das ist so ein seltenes ereignis also überhaupt ein waldbrand in schweden dass schweden gar keine löschflugzeuge
besitzt und die absolute katastrophe
15 dieser waldbrände können nicht mehr gelöscht werden sie sind vollkommen außer kontrolle geraten und wenn man sich die
wettervorhersagen ansieht werden sie noch wochen brennen regen wird es so bald nicht geben
in deutschland bringt dass die landwirte in bedrängnis das wichtigste getreide in deutschland ist der weizen und in vielen regionen
müssen die bauern die felder viel früher ernten und das obwohl die körner noch lange nicht so weit sind manche bauern ernten bis zu
40 prozent weniger getreide als normal und auch die rapsernte
fällt wohl deutlich kleiner aus als sonst einige landwirte
müssten so um ihre existenz fürchten so der bauernverband er fordert dass in betroffenen gebieten den notstand ausgerufen wird schon jetzt
werden vergleiche mit 2003 laut ein extrem trockenes jahr mit einer gewaltigen hitzewelle
august 2003 gab es in europa temperaturen bis zu rund
47 grad man muss sich das mal so biologisch vor augen führen das ist zehn grad mehr als unsere körpertemperatur also wirklich gefährlich
eine der größten naturkatastrophen
die der kontinent je gesehen hat flüsse waren ausgetrocknet wälder abgebrannt und
zehntausende menschen starben es traf vor allem ältere leute denn klimaanlagen versagten und die häuser waren überfüllt mit zu opfern aber auch
2018 hat es in sich schon seit dem frühling hält in den entsprechenden gebieten das muster an sonniges wetter mit trockener luft und diese
hochdruckgebiete werden kaum durch regen unterbrochen stabile wetterlage
hervorgerufen durch langsamer werdende jetstreams um die arktis die für immer weniger luft bewegung sorgen eine folge des klimawandels
doch wie ungewöhnlich ist solch eine trockenheit in deutschland wirklich
anfällig für wassermangel so hatte die un deutschland
2015 in ihrem wasser bricht eingestuft doch es gibt möglichkeiten das zu überbrücken die
versorgungsinfrastruktur in unserem land ist im gegensatz zu anderen ländern und kontinenten gut und betroffene regionen
können einfach über fernleitungen mit wasser versorgt werden der großraum stuttgart ist beispielsweise
abgesichert durch das anzapfen des bodensees gleich mehrere talsperren und trinkwasserspeicher
versorgen das ruhrgebiet doch in zukunft werden probleme mit trockenheit und dürre nicht kleiner werden im gegenteil der
niederschlags zyklus im mittel europa verschiebt sich schon seit jahren hin
immer mehr ins extreme im winter haben die regenmengen demnach rund um zehn prozent zugenommen deutlich trockener dagegen
präsentieren sich die sommermonate regionale klimamodelle
bestätigen dass und prognostizieren für deutschland eine höhere wahrscheinlichkeit für längeren
trockenphasen ja wie geht es also vor allem in diesem jahr hier in deutschland und auch weltweit
weiter wir bleiben dran wenn er kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp also klicks um
dann umgeht er die kapuze am boxi auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen
täglich und garantiert ein verliert auf klicken und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die höhe
auf blogger vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
klimawandel bestätigt skeptiker
endgültig widerlegt bis dann
bleibt dran